WITH HERE.
THEY ARE GOING TO BE ABLE TO
VIEW THE ENTIRETY OF THESE
DOCUMENTS, JIM.
>> THAT WILL BE VERY
INTERESTING.
WITH ME FORMER TRUMP WHITE HOUSE
PRESS SECRETARY STEPHANIE
GRISHAM AND NICK ACKERMAN.
NICK, IN CRIMINAL LAW YOU HAVE
AGGRAVATING CIRCUMSTANCES,
FACTORS THAT INCREASE THE
SEVERITY OF THE CRIME.
IS THAT HOW THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE WILL VIEW ANY NATIONAL
SECURITY FALLOUT IN THIS CASE?
WILL PROSECUTORS BE CLOSELY
WATCHING THE DAMAGE ASSESSMENT
FROM THE DNI, DO YOU THINK?
>> OH, ABSOLUTELY.
I MEAN, THAT'S A BIG ISSUE HERE.
IN FACT, I THINK THE PROSECUTORS
WILL BE INVESTIGATING SOME OF
THE SAME THINGS.
I MEAN, FOR EXAMPLE, THEY'RE
LOOKING AT THE VIDEOS THAT WERE
ON THE STORAGE AREA.
THEY'RE GOING TO WANT TO SEE WHO
MOVED THINGS IN AND OUT, WHEN
THEY DID IT IN RELATION TO
REQUESTS THAT THEY MADE.
I'M SURE THEY'RE GOING TO BE
FINGERPRINTING EVERY ONE OF
THOSE DOCUMENTS TO TRY AND
DETERMINE WHETHER ANYBODY ELSE
HAD ACCESS TO THEM AND WHO HAD
ACCESS TO THEM.
SO IN SOME WAYS, THESE TWO
INVESTIGATIONS ARE GOING TO
DOVETAIL, BUT KEEP IN MIND, THE
GRAND JURY INVESTIGATION IS
COVERED BY SECRECY UNDER WHAT'S
KNOWN AS RULE 6E.
SO FOR ANYTHING TO BE PROVIDED
FROM THE GRAND JURY FROM
TESTIMONY THAT'S PROVIDED IN THE
GRAND JURY, THEY'RE GOING TO
HAVE TO GET A SPECIAL ORDER FROM
A COURT IN ORDER TO PROVIDE THAT
INFORMATION TO THE INTELLIGENCE
COMMITTEE.
>> AND STEPHANIE, AS I WAS
READING THROUGH SOME OF THIS
REDACTED MATERIAL YESTERDAY, I
WAS REMEMBERING WHAT YOU SAID A
WEEK AGO THAT MAR-A-LAGO IS NOT
EXACTLY THE KIND OF PLACE WHERE
YOU STORE CLASSIFIED TOP SECRET
DOCUMENTS.
YOU KNOW, IT'S NOT HARD TO
IMAGINE THAT AFTER THIS
ASSESSMENT TRUMP'S ALLIES IN
CONGRESS WILL COME OUT AND TRY
TO DOWN PLAY THE NATIONAL
SECURITY IMPLICATIONS HERE AND
TRY TO DISCREDIT WHAT THE HEAD
OF THE INTELLIGENCE COMMUNITY
SAYS, BUT I MEAN, TALK ABOUT
THAT.
I MEAN, IT SEEMS PRETTY CLEAR
THAT THE DNI IS ESSENTIALLY
AGREEING WITH WHAT YOU WERE
SAYING A WEEK AGO.
>> YEAH, THAT'S RIGHT, JIM.
YOU KNOW, IT IS THE PRESIDENT'S
HOME SIX MONTHS OUT OF THE YEAR,
BUT IT IS ALSO A CLUB, A RESORT.
IT IS A RESORT THAT PUTS ITS
MEMBERS VERY FIRST, AND AS I'VE
TALKED ABOUT BEFORE, YOU KNOW,
THE GUESTS OF THE MEMBERS CAN
COME IN WITH VERY, VERY LITTLE
VETTING.
THEY CATER TO THEIR MEMBERS
WHICH THEY HAVE THE RIGHT TO DO.
BUT THERE ARE PEOPLE IN AND OUT
OF THERE CONSTANTLY WHO ARE NOT
NECESSARILY VETTED, SO THAT'S
A
PADLOCK?
IT SEEMS LAUGHABLE TO ME.
YOU KNOW, I'VE BEEN RACKING MY
BRAINS TO TRY TO EXPLAIN TO
PEOPLE WHY THIS IS IMPORTANT TO
THEM.
I THINK THAT'S WHAT'S -- YOU
KNOW, EVERYBODY WANTS TO KNOW
HOW DOES THIS AFFECT ME BOTTOM
LINE, AND I'VE BEEN REALLY
DISAPPOINTED TO SEE A LOT OF MY
REPUBLICAN COLLEAGUES ALREADY
DOWN PLAYING IT SAYING, OH, THEY
ONLY FOUND DOCUMENTS.
I'M NOT SURE WHAT THEY WERE
EXPECTING.
BUT RIGHT NOW AT THIS VERY
SECOND THERE ARE PEOPLE IN OUR
COUNTRY AND AROUND THIS WORLD
WHO ARE PROTECTING US.
THEY ARE UNDER COVER AND THEY'RE
PROTECTING US, WHETHER THEY'RE
WORKING FOR AN INTELLIGENCE
AGENCY OR THE MILITARY, THEY'RE
IN DANGEROUS SITUATIONS ALL THE
TIME PROTECTING US FROM THINGS
THAT WE HAVE NO IDEA ABOUT.
AND THE FACT THERE WERE
DOCUMENTS THERE THAT COULD BLOW
THESE PEOPLE'S COVER, IT SHOULD
WORRY PEOPLE BECAUSE IT PUTS
YOUR FAMILIES AT RISK, AND SO I
THINK THAT'S SOMETHING FOR
PEOPLE TO REALLY TRY TO
UNDERSTAND.
IT'S NOT JUST SOME DOCUMENTS
THAT WERE THROWN IN A BOX.
THESE ARE PEOPLE'S LIVES, AND
THESE ARE THE LIVES OF PEOPLE'S
FAMILIES.
>> RIGHT, AND NICK, LOOKING AT
THIS FROM A PROSECUTOR'S
PERSPECTIVE, WHAT STANDS OUT TO
YOU IF THE AFFIDAVIT IN THE CASE
THAT THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE
SEEMS TO BE BUILDING RIGHT NOW?
>> WELL, I THINK WHAT REALLY
STANDS OUT TO ME IS THE
OBSTRUCTION PIECE OF THIS.
I MEAN, THE CONCEALMENT THAT'S
LISTED IN THAT AFFIDAVIT, I
MEAN, THAT IS WHAT REALLY
TRIGGERED THIS SEARCH WARRANT IN
THE FIRST PLACE BECAUSE THEY HAD
EVIDENCE THAT THEY WERE BEING
LIED TO, THAT THEY WERE BEING
PLAYED, AND THAT DONALD TRUMP
AND SOME OTHERS WERE BASICALLY
CONCEALING THESE DOCUMENTS,
WHICH LEADS TO THE BIG QUESTION
WHY WOULD THEY EVEN WANT THESE
DOCUMENTS IN THE FIRST PLACE,
WHICH OF COURSE, BRINGS UP THIS
ISSUE OF WHAT HAPPENED TO THESE
DOCUMENTS, WHO HAD ACCESS TO
THEM, AND WERE THINK OF OUR REAL
MAJOR SECRETS BLOWN BECAUSE OF
THE WAY THIS MATERIAL WAS
HANDLED.
I THINK FROM A PROSECUTOR'S
STANDPOINT, IT'S THAT
OBSTRUCTION PIECE THAT REALLY IS
IMPORTANT HERE.
>> AND STEPHANIE, WE'VE SEEN A
NUMBER OF RESPONSES FROM TRUMP
REVEALING SOME OF HIS THINKING
OVER THE PAST SEVERAL DAYS, AND
SOME OF THESE TRUTH POSTS, AS
THEY'RE CALLED IN AN ORWELLIAN
SORT OF WAY, I GUESS, THEY
REVEAL WHAT APPEARS TO BE A GOOD
DEAL OF CONCERN ON HIS PART.
DO YOU THINK TRUMP IS FREAKING
OUT OVER THIS?
>> I THINK HE'S GOT TO BE
CONCERNED.
I DON'T KNOW HOW HE'S NOT.
I MEAN, THE MAN IS UNDER
INVESTIGATION SIX, SEVEN, EIGHT
WAYS, DIFFERENT INVESTIGATIONS,
AND NOW, YOU KNOW, PEOPLE HAVE
GONE INTO HIS HOME AND REMOVED
ACTUAL EVIDENCE: I THINK THE
FACT THAT HE KEEPS CHANGING HIS
MESSAGING TO ME AS SOMEBODY WHO
WORKED FOR HIM FOR SO LONG, THAT
IS VERY TELLING.
A LOT OF TIMES WITH DONALD
TRUMP, HE WILL GO TO A MESSAGE
AND STICK TO IT AND DOUBLE DOWN,
TRIPLE DOWN, EVEN IF IT'S
ABSOLUTELY THE WRONG MESSAGE.
THIS TIME THE MESSAGE KEEPS
CHANGING, WHETHER IT'S -- THEY
PLANTED EVIDENCE OR THEY
SHOULDN'T HAVE GONE IN.
I HAD NO NOTICE.
I WASN'T EVEN GIVEN A CHANCE OR
MOST RECENTLY, IT'S BEEN, YOU
KNOW, RELEASE EVERYTHING.
BE TRANSPARENT, AND SO THEY
RELEASED THIS AFFIDAVIT THAT'S
COMPLETELY SETTING PRECEDENT
THAT I'M NOT SURE WILL BE GOOD
IN THE FUTURE FOR FUTURE CASES
OR THE PRESIDENT OR FUTURE
PRESIDENTS, EXCUSE ME, AND NOW
THAT'S NOT ENOUGH EITHER.
WHAT ARE THESE REDACTIONS, YOU
KNOW, COVERING UP.
REALLY, THEY JUST WANT TO SEE
WHAT THE REDACTIONS ARE.
THEY WANT TO SEE WHO'S TALKING
TO THEM, AND THEY WANT TO SEE
EXACTLY WHAT THE DOJ HAS SO THEY
CAN START CRAFTING MESSAGES
AGAINST IT.
ALL THAT TO SAY, YES, I THINK HE
IS NERVOUS.
THIS ISN'T LIKE HIM TO CHANGE
HIS MESSAGE SO OFTEN.
HE'S MUCH BETTER AT PR THAN
THAT.
I KNOW THAT SOUNDS SILLY, BUT
USUALLY WHEN HE JUST TRIPLES
DOWN ON ANYTHING NO MATTER HOW
BONKERS OR FALSE IT IS, HE GETS
AWAY WITH IT.
>> RIGHT, AND HE HAS BEEN ALL
OVER THE PLACE ON THIS.
AND NICK, I MEAN, BUT HE HASN'T
EXPLAINED WHY HE HAD THE
DOCUMENTS, AND NICK, TRUMP'S
ATTORNEYS SUBMITTED A FILING
LAST NIGHT FURTHER EXPLAINING
THEIR REQUEST THAT AN
INDEPENDENT SPECIAL MASTER
REVIEW THESE MATERIALS RECOVERED
BY THE FBI.
DO YOU THINK THE JUDGE WILL
ACTUALLY DO THAT?
WHY COMPLY WITH THAT REQUEST?
>> THERE'S NO GOOD REASON TO
COMPLY WITH THAT REQUEST.
BASICALLY IT'S BASED ON THE
PREDICATE THAT THE SPECIAL
MASTER WOULD REVIEW PRIVILEGED
DOCUMENTS.
FIRST OF ALL, ANYTHING THAT IS
COVERED BY EXECUTIVE PRIVILEGE
IS NOT SOMETHING THAT HE CAN
ASSERT.
HE'S LOST THAT BATTLE IN THE
SUPREME COURT.
HE'S BEEN THERE.
HE'S DONE IT, AND HE'S LOST.
THE ONLY OTHER ITEM THAT COULD
POSSIBLY BE PRIVILEGED HERE IS
ATTORNEY/CLIENT PRIVILEGE, AND
WHAT HE RELIES ON IN HIS PAPERS
QUITE AMAZINGLY ARE THE
SITUATIONS WHERE HIS TWO
LAWYERS, RUDY GIULIANI AND
MICHAEL COHEN HAD SPECIAL
MASTERS APPOINTED FOR THEM WHEN
THERE WAS SEARCHES OF THEIR HOME
AND OFFICE.
THE FACT OF THE MATTER IS WHEN
YOU'RE DEALING WITH A LAWYER WHO
HAS LOTS OF CLIENTS AND CLEARLY
ATTORNEY/CLIENT PRIVILEGED
INFORMATION, THAT IS A TOTALLY
DIFFERENT SITUATION, AND WHAT IS
REALLY MISSING FROM THESE
PAPERS, IT IS SO BLATANT AND SO
GLARING, IS THAT THERE IS NOT
ONE IOTA OF PROOF THERE WAS
ANYTHING IN ANY OF THESE BOXES
THAT WAS COVERED BY AN
ATTORNEY/CLIENT PRIVILEGE.
THE PROPER WAY TO DO THIS IF IT
REALLY EXISTED WAS FOR DONALD
TRUMP TO SUBMIT A DECLARATION OR
AN AFFIDAVIT POINTING OUT THAT
THERE ARE CERTAIN COMMUNICATIONS
IN THERE THAT WERE BETWEEN HIM
AND HIS ATTORNEYS.
HE'S FAILED TO DO THAT.
I MEAN, IF I WERE THE JUDGE, I
WOULD JUST DISMISS THIS OUT OF
HAND.
>> AND STEPHANIE, ANOTHER THING
THAT YOU KNOW ABOUT WHEN IT
COMES TO DONALD TRUMP IS HOW HE
LIKES TO GET TO THE BOTTOM OF
LEAKS AND ONE OF THE THINGS THAT
I NOTICED IN THIS AFFIDAVIT THAT
WAS RELEASED YESTERDAY, EVEN
WITH ALL OF THOSE REDACTIONS IS
THAT IT MENTIONS LOTS OF
WITNESSES WHO ARE INTEGRAL TO
THIS INVESTIGATION.
I HAVE TO THINK THAT TRUMP IS,
YOU KNOW, GOING A LITTLE MAD
RIGHT NOW TRYING TO FIGURE OUT
WHO THESE LEAKERS ARE, WHO THESE
WITNESSES MIGHT BE.
>> I COMPLETELY AGREE WITH YOU.
I'VE SAID THAT DEFINITELY FROM
THE START.
SOMETHING I FOUND INTERESTING
ABOUT THE AFFIDAVIT MENTIONING
WITNESSES, BEFORE, YOU KNOW, I
THOUGHT IT WAS ONE OR TWO, AND
OBVIOUSLY TWO COULD BE THE
WITNESSES.
I THOUGHT IT WAS JUST SOMEBODY
CLOSE TO HIM, WHICH I STILL
BELIEVE IT IS BECAUSE OF SOME OF
THE DETAILS THAT THE FBI AND THE
DOJ HAD WHEN THEY WENT TO
MAR-A-LAGO.
BUT NOW A CONCERN I HAVE IS, YOU
KNOW, IF THERE ARE MORE THAN
ONE, IF THERE ARE PLURAL
WITNESSES, HE'S GOT SUCH A SMALL
GROUP AROUND HIM, I'M WONDERING
IF HE HAS TAKEN THINGS OUT OF
THOSE BOXES AND SHOWN THEM
AROUND AND PERHAPS SOME OF THE
PEOPLE HE HAS SHOWN THESE THINGS
TO HAVE SPOKEN UP.
THAT WILL BE INCREDIBLY DAMNING
IF THAT'S THE CASE.
THE FACT THAT THERE MAY BE, YOU
KNOW, MORE THAN ONE WITNESS,
MORE THAN TWO WITNESSES MAKES ME
JUST WONDER IF IT'S A BIGGER
CIRCLE, AGAIN, PEOPLE HE HAS
SHOWN THINGS TO.